[Music]
four years ago
i was in a psych ward i was blindsided
by shrieks of accusations
being hurled my way you why are you
spying on me
stop following me just because i'm
famous
doesn't mean you can invade my privacy
i was a medical student at the johns
hopkins hospital when i first learned
what a delusion was a belief that is
persistently held
despite evidence to the contrary
over these past four years i've realized
just how widespread
delusions are in our society
we have grammy award-winning artists who
believe that the moon landing was faked
and we have professional basketball
players who believe that the earth is
flat
but when people put on their tinfoil
hats put tape over their webcams
and wait for the re-emergence of the
lizard people we laugh them off
instead of worrying about their mental
health but just because a conspiracy
theory is funny
doesn't mean it's a joke
deep down conspiracy theories are
symptoms of a broader problem
the fundamental attribution error or
the fae this is the tendency to prefer
explanations
based on perceived intent and motive
rather than circumstance and coincidence
today my core message to you is the fae
is alive
in your daily life i'm going to show you
three ways
in which this bias plays a role in your
life pandemic conspiracy theories
minority oppression and self-help
gospels
while flat earth truthers may seem
harmless
conspiracy theories can be more serious
than you would think
theories espoused by a q anon such as
the coven 19 virus was developed in a
lab
or the vaccine contains tracking
microchips
can have seriously damaging consequences
on the health and livelihoods
of people worldwide these theories are
often more appealing than the truth
because they offer people an illusion of
control
for many the pandemic is terrifying
poorly understood and massively
disruptive
my grandmother is one of these people
before the pandemic
she was a super social person but now
her life has been completely uprooted
and she blames it on numerous
unfounded conspiracies in a crisis like
this
it's easy for her to believe that an
evil plot
being orchestrated by evil villains all
acting in concert
is the responsible agent for the
pandemic
more challenging for her to believe is
that
the world came to a grinding halt
because one small virus
from one small bat made a series of
jumps to an unlucky man in a chinese
marketplace
because that's too insignificant
too unsatisfying a reason
for people like my grandmother they
believe these theories because of the
fae
they assign someone's ulterior motives
to the origins of the pandemic
rather than sheer chance
to change their views we must first
realize that
these people are not delusional but
rather
they too just want to understand and
have certainty
during these trying times
rather than lambasting them for their
beliefs
or censoring them on twitter we should
empathize with them
and equip them with the tools so that
they can overcome these false beliefs
on their own we need to make people more
media
and science literate research has found
that taking critical thinking classes
actually reduces your susceptibility
to conspiracy theories by making people
question the facts behind their own
beliefs as hard as that may be
they can overcome conspiracy theories
and the fae
on their own again
my core message to you today is the fae
is alive
in your life next
let's talk about minority oppression how
about a quiz
true or false hard work
talent and personal perseverance are the
keys to success
and wealth if you answered true then you
have fallen victim
to the fae in reality
the best way to die rich in america is
to be born rich
for every rags-to-riches headline we see
there are countless
untold stories of poverty and misfortune
we rush to celebrate those who succeed
against all odds
yet regularly overlook why the odds were
so long
in the first place for so many people
the levers of destiny are out of their
grasp
so why do we even overlook these odds in
the first place
society would have us believe that we
live in a just
world where the world is the way it is
for a good reason
and that those who have it bad must have
done something to deserve it
the black kid who got shot should not
have been running away from the police
the woman who was assaulted should not
have dressed that way
as someone who suffered from an eating
disorder and could not receive treatment
for over a year
i am pained when i hear people claim
that overweight and obese people should
simply
have more willpower and eat less
those in power blame individuals to
distract away
from the systemic change and empathy for
others
that our society truly needs
we must recognize this how can we hope
to change
our unequal and unfair systems in
society
if we do not recognize our own roles in
perpetuating
these beliefs
if we wish to weave equality into the
fabric of our society
we must first begin by assessing the
nature of our own convictions
the fae is alive in your daily life
next let's talk about something that i
hold dear
i love self-help books my bookshelf is
full of books
winning friends and influence and not
giving a [ __ ]
marie condos the life-changing magic of
tidying up
was as life-changing to me as the title
suggests
i even received self-help books for my
birthday
now i don't know what that says about
what my friends think about me
but i can tell you what that reveals
about what i believed
that if only i acted and behaved better
i could live
a better life our society forces this
gospel of self-help
upon all of us we're told to shore up
our inadequate abilities
fix our character flaws and overcome our
individual obstacles and weaknesses
but this approach has one crucial flaw
the fae
because it does not consider the role of
context
the problem with self-help isn't that
you're unable to help yourself
but rather it falsely promises
that you and you alone are responsible
for your successes
and failures
in reality your individual qualities
and your environment determine your
behavior
but the biggest piece of this
explanatory pie is circumstance and so
if we wish to accomplish our self-help
goals
we must structure our surroundings in
such a way
that it reduces our need to be so
self-reliant on our individual decisions
and willpower for example if you want to
eat more healthily
you shouldn't rely on your willpower to
stop you from eating all the cookies
instead you should fill your cupboards
and refrigerators with healthy snacks
instead of junk food if you want to
write that novel
you should set aside an hour every day
to jot down words instead of waiting for
inspiration to strike
if we structure our surroundings to set
us up for success
perhaps we won't have to be so hard on
ourselves in the future
so let me summarize whether through the
conspiracy theories of others
societal minority oppression or your own
beliefs about yourself
the fundamental attribution error plays
a critical role
in molding how you interact with society
and the shape of society itself
my challenge for you is to not only
become aware
of this error but also to refuse its
seductive pull
here are three ways one practice
empathy and gratitude especially when in
discussions with others about their
opinion
two practice self-awareness look inwards
and critically assess the facts that
underlie your beliefs
and three pause think about the
circumstances that could be at play
before judging others give people
the benefit of the doubt if there's one
thing you can take away from this talk
i hope it's this give yourself and
others
a break thank you
you